in 2006 Jennifer Carpenter was an
up-and-coming actress whose luck changed
virtually overnight when she booked the
second lead on Showtime's breakout
serial killer drama Dexter carpenter
frequently stole the spotlight from
Michael C hall with her impassioned turn
as Dexter's foster sister Deborah a
homicide detective whose caseload often
overlapped with her duplicity brother's
own crimes it's been almost seven years
since Dexter's devicive finale episode
aired and fans are still wondering if
carpenters Deborah got the send-off she
deserved as for Carpenter herself she's
maintained a lower profile recently but
she's more than kept herself busy since
leaving Deborah and Dexter behind like
so many actors in and around Hollywood
over the past decade or so Jennifer
Carpenter eventually found herself with
a ticket to ride the Marvel Money Train
but it wasn't quite of the first-class
nature she only got to contribute her
voice to the ever-expanding Marvel verse
through the animated project Avengers
confidential Black Widow and Punisher in
the 2014 anime film its carpenters
golden pipes and not Scarlett
Johansson's you hear as tough as nails
Natasha Romanov evening castle what have
you got there friend of yours
Marvel's Black Widow isn't the only big
time comic book character Jennifer
Carpenter has voiced since her days on
Dexter her second turn in the animated
comic book movie world found her voicing
Selina Kyle best known as Gotham City's
Catwoman in Warner Brothers and DC
comics lavish 19th century reimagining
of the Dark Knight saga Batman Gotham by
Gaslight released to largely positive
reviews in 2018 Gotham by Gaslight was
adapted from the 1989 graphic novel of
the same name itself the first official
offering from DC's Elseworlds imprint
both the book and the film featured
Bruce Wayne defending the streets of a
gloriously steampunky Gotham as a
victorian-era Batman eventually facing
off against the infamous killer Jack the
Ripper
but Carpenter hasn't shied away from
performing in front of the camera as
well since leaving Dexter behind the
actress has sought out similar success
on the small screen that search
ultimately led the actress to the
hyper-competitive realm of network
television where she's delivered strong
work in largely forgettable dramas the
first of carpenters post Dexter TV roles
came on the short-lived dramedy
limitless which was based on the Bradley
Cooper starring movie of the same name
that flick found Cooper
the life fantastic after ingesting a
wonder drug that enabled him to utilize
the full potential of his brain the
television adaptation which was produced
by Cooper and Joker director Todd
Phillips followed a similar set up this
time however the gifted man is out to
make the world a safer place and
Carpenter portrays the FBI agent tasked
with helping focus the man's energies on
solving crimes you will have plenty of
stuff to go through the morning
carpenters next television venture found
her playing the other side of the law as
a traitorous former CIA agent forced to
team up with the FBI
to help track down their most-wanted spy
titled the enemy within
carpenters timely espionage drama had
the look of a winner when it hit the air
in 2019 but tragically never found its
audience and was cancelled after airing
just 13 episodes
the actress seems to have had better
luck on the big screen having found a
patron of sorts in cinematic rabble
rouser s Kraig Kahler
whose modern b-movie marvels include
brawl in cell block 99 and 2019 s
disturbing dirty cop caper dragged
across concrete in the hyper violent
brawl in cell block 99 carpenter plays
alar and Thomas the wife of Vince
Vaughn's Bradley Thomas a retired boxer
whose life of crime lands him behind
bars at the Redleaf Correctional
Facility where his troubles only grow
more intense throughout it all Carpenter
stayed devoted to the madness while
breathing necessary life into a
character that's not quite 3-dimensional
she did the same and dragged across
concrete bringing a refreshing humanity
to tortured young mother Kelly summer
who serves as a smaller character
against leaves Mel Gibson and Vince
Vaughn who play a pair of cops suspended
after assaulting a suspect in late 2019
Carpenter was cast in the film on
mouthful of air alongside Amanda
Seyfried and Britt Robertson the film is
an adaptation of Amy cop woman's novel
of the same name and centers on a new
mother and children's book author who
uses her own imaginary world as a means
of escape from postpartum depression
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]